Bernie Sanders has absolutely destroyed
third corridor campaign fundraising the
third quarter just ended at the end of
September and it ended as Bernie Sanders
most successful fundraising period of
his entire 2020 campaign so let's back
up as you probably know or would suspect
I hate how politics is funded here in
the United States the system is broken
the game is broken it's a corrupt game
it has it's a game with rules that don't
make any sense
fundraising super PACs dark money
Citizens United money is speech I mean
it's really horrifying what is going on
but right now this is the system that we
have and the way you win elections is by
raising a whole bunch of money so it
still matters and it can be a sign in
the system that we have of enthusiasm
for candidates it's it can be a sort of
proxy indicator so to speak and Bernie
Sanders raised 25 million dollars in the
third quarter of this year so in terms
of polling Bernie Sanders has not had a
good third quarter the momentum has been
behind Elizabeth Warren in the polling
as I've said much to the disgust of many
people in my audience but I will always
tell it to you like it is but that's
polling in fundraising Bernie Sanders is
more than excelling now reporting more
than 1 million individual donors to his
campaign that symmetric he achieved
faster than any Democratic presidential
candidate ever and there's some very
interesting data that's been released by
the Sanders campaign the most common
profession among Bernie's donors is
teachers the most common employers among
Bernie's donors are Walmart Amazon and
Starbucks which I mean what you have to
understand is they're some of the
largest employers in the country so I
wouldn't be surprised if more than one
candidate can't out lots of donors from
Walmart Amazon and Starbucks but still
interesting nonetheless so we now have
an interesting situation with the fourth
Democratic presidential debate coming up
in just over two weeks actually two
weeks to the day we now have an
interesting situation with Bernie
Sanders and Elizabeth Warren
there's the Joe Biden question as the
centrist establishment can
and then there is the Bernie Warren we
are the most progressive candidates who
have a shot at this thing sort of status
quo that we're dealing with on the one
hand
Bernie's fundraising is absolutely
unmatched the numbers tell us this on
the other hand Elizabeth Warren
continues to build momentum in the polls
so what could potentially cause things
to break one way or the other one thing
we do need to talk about is media
coverage I just saw a report although I
did not fact check it but it alleges
that ABC News devoted only seven minutes
so far period in all of their evening
newscasts to Bernie Sanders campaign
which seems absolutely and totally
bonkers this is not again this is not me
shilling for one get one candidate or
the other it's just pointing out that
given the level of support Bernie does
have which has been sort of going back
and forth between being in second and
third place seven minutes of coverage
seems quite low
we should fact check that so media
coverage is going to be a big thing
another one is debates but the the
caveat about debates is that debates
don't seem to have had the effect on
Bernie's polling that maybe we would
have imagined Bernie Sanders I was
looking back at the polling today I've
not identified any significant or
notable jumps that Bernie Sanders had
after debates we've seen drops for Joe
Biden seems that the debates have not
been particularly good for Joe Biden
Elizabeth Warren has been steadily
gaining since the start of the debates
and even before that most everybody else
has been relatively unaffected there's
you know one Emerson poll that has
Andrew yang at 8% whether we can trust
that one poll with that high number and
whether it's related to the debates
these are open questions but for Bernie
it does not seem to have done much one
way or the other so we'll see what
happens as far as the debates go
it's terrible to go back to the real
core of the issue here it's terrible
that the name of the game is raising
money it's terrible that this is how
politics is done it's terrible that
congressional terms are two years and
when you combine that with the system of
fundraising that we have as soon as
you're elected you have four to five
months and then you've got to start
raising money and campaigning for your
reelection if you plan to do that so
it's a terrible game that has to be
played for as long as it is the
game that is being played you want to
see the more progressive candidates
raised the most money and Bernie Sanders
has raised a ton of it in the third
quarter of 2019 we'll continue to follow
fundraising numbers